for to a real [ __ ] boxing gym i'll
get rounds and where i'll drop
everything yeah i'm not losing to a guy
that doesn't box you see the fire in his
eyes bro
i refuse i'm telling you bro he got it
he got the hate in his heart would you
prefer to do boxing or kickboxing if his
kickball i would prefer kickboxing i
would
love to [ __ ] rip somebody's legs in
half oh my god bro see
hey you're getting his his dick is hard
right now you know let's tell you guys
listening at home and watching this
hey that [ __ ] levitating what's going on
this guy him thinking about breaking
someone's leg off
he's literally in five foe
three two one alex
hit it off with that freestyle cut no
beat uh
what yeah i ain't free what ain't no
freestyle got my baby girl
yeah we going wild yeah i'm wifed up huh
yeah i'm
wifed up huh don't talk to me because
i'm
wifed up hey man my man rhymed no words
just said
on this very special episode of the
genius brain podcast
i had a date expert come through here to
help alex out
and now my man alex off that market
let's go off the market baby do you
think that that dating expert helped
nah he was cool but nah
[Applause]
and i used one you didn't walk up to her
with the mad confidence and like that he
told you to
yeah did you ask what her 10-year plan
was
like no i didn't no none of that work he
was cool though
i mean he was nice to me but yeah i was
some of the [ __ ]
he was telling me i was like all right
like i can't do that what was the one
thing he said where you're like i don't
know if i can do this like to just go up
to
especially when he started talking to us
and he was telling us like oh i'm gonna
take you to the bar
but he started telling me like i go up
to girls and people will be like i like
your vibe
i'm like oh yeah i'm not doing that i'll
tell you this though listen
i've seen people go up to a bar tell
women i like their vibe and i'll tell
you right now
fails every time so bro if you come up
to somebody and you say that i
immediately think you're a serial killer
yeah i think there's
you have something that's like why would
you say that you know what it is like i
i know where he's coming from like that
type of [ __ ] works on a very specific
time yeah yeah
it's in miami like for real it's like
these [ __ ] that are
that just want to [ __ ] or they they
think that you're rich
or some [ __ ] like they're just looking
for a good [ __ ] time to like this guy
might have some [ __ ] money oh i see
let's get smashed together yeah like you
like my vibe oh my god where are you
from
yeah yeah but if you're not trying to
beat it
i'm a miami girl and you're gonna hit on
me real quick all right fat ass
blue hair and i like your vibe hey a
little [ __ ] up in the face though but
about the body toy
there you go oh hey oh my bad my bad you
here by yourself my bad my bad are you
is this chair taken
no it's not where you from
hey can i get one beer please
where are you from do you know her hey
where are you from bro i'm from
california
you know what i like your vibe i think
there's i think i've seen you before in
another past life because i was
literally
in a past life i was literally an
african i was an african tribe
and i had six children and guess what
you look like one of my kids from the my
past
and i want to say this right now that i
don't mean a lot of people like you but
that shirt
it really matches my eyes what i'm
saying is we should have sex later on
what is your name what do you do what's
your 10-year plan let's have sex right
now
in the middle of this bar i swear to
[ __ ] god if you don't leave with me
right now i'll kill you
beside relief my name's nick dunn hey
uh my 10-year plan i'm gonna train
i gotta tell you guys i'm in love and it
works every time that for sure happened
to you or bro
but that was the thing like when they
started talking about okay yeah the next
one we're gonna go to a bar
and i'm gonna have you do these pickup
lines i was like i was like hey david
please
say hey david please please i like this
i want it to around the money
hey here's the thing though i also have
anxiety i wouldn't be able to deal with
that [ __ ]
it's kind of hard that way i listen i'm
not saying that i can't talk to women
yeah but to do it in that type of way
it's very very that's the thing i can
obviously talk to women but like if i
get put where i
have these things i need to go say or
like i have to hit like a
checkpoint of like i'm like bro i'm
going to go over checking oh i like your
vibe
and [ __ ] it's just like bro i ain't
doing how would you hit on a girl that
you thought was fine as [ __ ]
but she kind of giving you lightweight
signals that she want to talk to you
all right bro david's blind he's like
he's like how do you really talk
tell me right now if you didn't if you
didn't say that she was giving me
signals i was about to be like i
wouldn't
write with you nah i don't know i just
like
obviously you know you you know just
like i think the biggest thing for me is
like working out right because
you train all the time you're like oh we
should go work out sometimes now but you
had a bar bro you're not in your job
that's the thing bro i don't ever go to
bars so that's going to work out
tomorrow
but you're in miami you have to be at
about miami you're in miami right now
it's about i say uno dos trace quattro
o'clock
i don't know is quattro o'clock right
now i might be sleepy by that time but
all right
nice quattro o'clock you see this dodge
game time baby this dime piece and she
kind of giving you that side eye like
look
oh [ __ ] i think i'm down the [ __ ]
what do you say though uh i feel like
[ __ ] i might be down the foot too
say that yeah she's gotta get it out
she's sitting next to you and then she
goes
is anybody sitting here oh that's like
no no you can go ahead sit down
be like oh you chilling by yourself are
you visiting or are you from miami tight
he already in yeah he's saying
he know what he's doing he knows he's
right you're not gonna watch i wouldn't
do that
i promise you're not getting me in
trouble right now
i'm talking about alex of the old
because alex got a lady now
man you got a special lady so what did
you guys get together
uh i think we've been official now for
like a month and a half now that's new
it's new what the [ __ ] i still like it
boot up she
she still kind of initiated it oh you
[ __ ] ass [ __ ]
okay all the girls that talk to this
fool always initiate yeah
but this one it was not like that you
remember that it is what it is dude yeah
it must be nice you know yeah it was
cool though bro cuz like what started is
because like
i posted a song about this band that i
really like alice and chains
oh yeah you know that band yeah yeah you
know allison chandler yeah yeah
they come to snuff the rooster yeah
featuring tupac
yeah if you dream too far yeah he's like
rooster [ __ ] yeah yeah
and then so yeah she liked it so that
kind of like
started the conversation and then we
kind of just figured out like oh we like
a lot of the same [ __ ] we like to hike
we like the same foods we like same
music
she likes mma she's trained jiu jitsu
she's trained muay thai she went to
thailand for three months to try to
bro yeah bruh so like everything is just
like all right you guys spar yet
yeah i started scrapping yeah i'm like
bing bing we giving each other the bean
binking [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
but yeah it's been good it's been fun
damn what's it feel like to not be
single again man it's been a hot minute
though
over three years hey can i tell you guys
something real quick though this is the
funniest [ __ ] about this [ __ ]
all right
we've been trying to get this dude to
train seriously for i don't know like a
year
right like let's say yo this public
giggling right now but because
it's true he comes through
he comes through he hits past maybe 10
seconds he go man i'm big tired
this will get a girl this guy
yeah dad i've never seen a guy i've
never seen this whole
hit pad so hard in my life this one's
out here trying to prove something to
somebody right hey
alex's famous words would always be like
if i get a girl then i'm gonna do xyz
and bro this dude
i've never seen his car cleaner i've
never seen his room cleaner bruh
he's a man of his word though you know
he said once he says he's gonna do it
he's gonna this will decide to work more
hours and make money and [ __ ] now
i'm like who is this guy i haven't seen
this dude [ __ ] is going on
i'm trying to get busy again you know
what i'm saying [ __ ] he was like i just
saw you all three weeks ago
it wasn't three weeks bro it wasn't
three weeks yeah well
there's only two weeks ago then because
we just didn't train this week but i saw
you that was a couple weeks ago yeah
yeah yeah nah that [ __ ] was like a month
ago i locally tried to hang out with
nick yesterday i top restaurant he's
like no i don't want to see you i don't
want to see your girlfriend don't ever
ask me
i i couldn't go because i had a
maintenance guy in my house this is what
it is now now i know when he says he's
tired he can't do [ __ ]
it's all [ __ ] lies dude yeah it's all
live i've never seen somebody throw a
hook so hard at a pad in my life dude
this won't say it
what the [ __ ] man that's what i knew he
had a girlfriend dude he changed he
changed bro
girl uh girlfriend alex is a different
kind of alex bro
better alex more potent you know i don't
even think people know this fool has
been with uh
tiff for like a thousand years yeah one
thousand years bro
since high school right yeah it's gonna
be 12 years in uh
january did you guys ever almost break
up kind of a little bit
but she was just tripping though she see
what's wrong
hey your fault it's her fault bro now we
would just get
i forgot like yeah what would you guys
fight about
in the beginning like when you're in
high school and [ __ ] bro like we
wouldn't fight that much
like we it would just be about little
[ __ ] you know like just cause like bro
when you're a kid like when you're in
high school
the things you fight about is just the
pettiest stuff because you don't know
who the [ __ ] you are
yeah you get offended by everything you
take everything personal so you think
everything is a slight against you you
know especially
when you're younger but you know it
still happens as you get older as well
but you just learn how to manage those
things a little bit better but
yeah man like we've been there for so
long it's kind of crazy to think about
yeah she's ready to break up with me any
day now
i've been trying to get her to break it
with you for the longest time every time
david sees her and gives her a hug he
always goes
you know you could always do better he's
like he's like tap my back twice if
you're safe and he goes and goes i have
a plenty of guys for you yeah i said
plethora i use the big words
my man i got a [ __ ] horde of dudes
and tiff is so deep in it she's just
like
okay and then walks away bro she has no
idea she has no idea there's better out
there
oh there's so much dude everything has
no idea every time there's a better
looking guy this fool just literally
shields her eyes
yeah she like i cover her eyes hey you
love me right you love me right you love
me right you might tell me you love me
tell me you love me
it's a very abusive relationship all
jokes aside you guys been the other
sister what 14 13
12 uh no like 17
17. how do you know 28.
are you 28. yeah boy oh yeah because
your birthday is september so you turn
29 this year
what'd you guys do on your 10 year
anniversary i proposed
oh oh this full [ __ ] way where did
you propose that
uh point doom in malibu crazy oh okay
isn't that where you guys got married to
in malibu yeah you're quite close to it
but you know
oh [ __ ] this fool did waited 10 years to
finally propose to her just for that
clean ass number
you know what i mean i'm i'm very
sentimental you haven't fought yet
yet at all huh no no that's it no no i
can't wait
it's still the beginning it's always
about to be some little [ __ ] though no i
mean
yeah we were cool but like what's cool
is like i don't know we haven't fought
but like
david will give you something to fight
about right now hey let me tell you
something how cute my lady is dude when
we first got together this girl said the
funniest thing dude
she let me dead in my soul she was like
we get along so well i don't know what
we'd ever fight about i literally
laughed at her face
she's like david's like here i'll tell
you right
i started laughing and she's like why
what's so funny i was like listen
i know this is like your first serious
relationship yeah the fights that we're
gonna get into
they're gonna be explosive yeah it's
gonna be over the dumbest things it's
real bro
you just don't know what it is because
when you're first in love you always had
this idea of
you know what we click yeah like yeah
when i left nothing was gonna break
us i eat you eat yeah when i shower you
mean sean
that's all you guys talk about you guys
talk about because you're exploring each
other you're finding out the best things
that you love about each other
but one day it's gonna be some [ __ ] like
alex's gonna fart real funny and she's
gonna be like what the [ __ ]
and then she gonna say some [ __ ] like
this she goes dude you know what i
didn't even never like your sky crew
tattoo
oh you're like and then you're gonna do
this you're gonna do that [ __ ] will you
smile
but you gotta piss you'd be like hey
what'd you say [ __ ]
and you'd be like i never liked the sky
crew thing what is that like sky vodka
is like one of the worst vodkas ever and
you'd be like
hey real quick put all these gloves
put on these gloves [ __ ] can you
[ __ ] hurt me right now that's gonna
happen word for word bro
word for word yeah it's gonna be some
small [ __ ] that she didn't think that
was gonna offend you
and then you're gonna be like low key
that's that's what you argue about in
the beginning
it's like because you're learning each
other's boundaries you're learning what
each other's buttons are
you know but it's all part of it though
you got to know that you got to go
through that [ __ ]
if if you don't have arguments with your
significant other
obviously not all the time but like you
know you should be having some
yeah that is boring bro when people
don't fight um
they always fight the most i've i
literally knew a couple
that had this huge facade this is how
funny it is right like
like back in the day i used to live with
these two i see them
every day i know you [ __ ] fight
david's like eating on the middle of the
couch they're fighting on the left like
legit
throwing hands there's like this is a
shitty ass apartment there's like a thin
ass paper thin wall
and i just hear it like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you think you [ __ ] know
everything i didn't think i know
everything i'm saying i know you and
your stupid tendencies
screaming at each other that's [ __ ]
real [ __ ] and i'm just sitting here just
eating my bowl of fruit loops like hey
blood you always [ __ ] too
what the [ __ ] are you up to you know and
i'm over here just like trying to manage
you
i know go to sleep mind your own [ __ ]
business yeah and i can't help it
because my boy i cut out a plastic cup i
said hello
right and i'm listening to them fight
constantly every day and i [ __ ] you not
we had a bunch of friends over for
dinner and this [ __ ]
looked directly into these people's eyes
and said did me
and my boyfriend i don't even we never
fight
and i'm like yo i was just there last
night
those people are full of [ __ ] they want
people to think that they're completely
fine and fantastic
you look at their instagram the loviest
dubbiest photos you'll ever see
them just [ __ ] kissing each other
twirling each other in the [ __ ] air
like a bunch of losers
yeah hold up my friends this podcast is
brought to you by ipvanish for those of
you who don't know ipvanish is a vpn or
a virtual private network that helps you
safely browse the internet
simply put if you are on your computer
doing just about anything and you don't
have a vpn by ipvanish are you nuts
people in web stoopers are all up in
your business and i'm not judging you
or looking at what you're looking at
online or maybe i am because you don't
have
ipvanish but that business is your
business and it should always be your
business and yo
data my friends here's everything you
get with ipvanish anonymous ip
addresses this means your personal ip
address can't be tracked by anyone on
the web
circumvent any online censorship get
protection when using public wi-fi so
basically
nobody can snoop on your data or see
what you're doing online so go to
ipvanish.com
brain claim your 65 savings they have
plans starting at just 349 a month or
27.99 a year
this is the time to sign up with our
discount and their current promotional
offerings
you can get a vpn for 65 off their usual
offerings ipvanish is the best of the
best even rated 4.7 out of 5 on
trustpilot
and that's with more than 6 000 reviews
show these guys some love remember it's
ipvanish.combrain
to get the deal and start protecting
yourself online and you got his legs
wrapped around her
just like that's the best meme ever
right now she's sitting on a [ __ ]
still she's playing in her hair
yeah she's holding it like this too dude
[ __ ] that they would fight about was
[ __ ] crazy and i was just gonna sit
there pretend like it's not even
happening
yeah like she would say some horrendous
stuff she
she made fun of his like job his career
damn bro if you're doing that [ __ ] you
gotta y'all gotta break up
that machine don't respect you that
sounds like my that's the thing
together are you talking were you
roommates with my parents
is that who you were they got three kids
one kid's ears [ __ ] up
i remember the the fights my parents
used to have like in white people terms
that's like domestic
violence type of [ __ ] but i feel like
immigrant parents they just be fighting
bro
yeah and they still stay together no
matter what they'd be squabbing bro
dude my trade-off my mom threw a rice
cooker on my dad one time
hey my mom too hey what's up reloaded
bro
rice was everywhere because everywhere
yeah my mom threw a rice cooker at my
dad my mom used to beat us with uh this
metal shoe horn till
it got bent out of shape so hard she
couldn't use it
she goes to hit anymore it just wraps
around your body
she's like go get me the rice but you're
like okay dude there's like weird stuff
that when i when i look if i go to a
therapist
i'm pretty sure they could unlock these
traumatizing memories right
are you because i was telling tip like
me to have conversations about this show
all the time where i'm starting to
realize like
how i react to certain things and it's
based off like
[ __ ] my parents used to do or my sisters
used to do and just growing up with it
and you're like oh [ __ ] like
i'm kind of [ __ ] up a little bit you
know not as bad i could be
obviously could be way [ __ ] worse but
in your own head you're like oh [ __ ]
like
this is kind of a problem in my life a
little bit you know what's something
that you do that your parents did
well it's just always like i second
guess everything that i do
just because like i would always hear my
family just like condemn and like talk
[ __ ] all the time and just like
just like oh is that why you [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] all the time it's like hey
this is what i think but actually maybe
this well hold on but yeah
i'm a flip-flopper i'm a flip-flopper
because i'm like i'm constantly like oh
[ __ ]
but uh no it's it's like i constantly
always think
that like what i'm doing is like [ __ ]
up or something like it's weird it's
super weird but your parents used to
like over correct you a lot
yeah my mom was a big over corrector
like she wouldn't let me
like i see other kids how their parents
let them explore [ __ ]
and maybe it's because i'm the youngest
where like i didn't get
that phase maybe i don't know maybe they
did that with my older sisters and [ __ ]
but like they would my my mom would over
correct everything
just super like what are you doing like
what are you [ __ ] dumb like
like that's like stupid or something
that's crazy you know crazy but
and it's also like you know i see i
i actually see that's crazy because i
actually see that behavior now
with uh a very specific friend of mine
yeah yeah
where this parent specifically over
corrects their child to the point
where now this child is exhibiting
behaviors that she
hates people pleasing yeah she hates it
then but now her child is doing the
exact same thing low-key when you were
telling me those stories
i realized i was like oh that's that's
kind of like me
because for so long like you know i'm
still going through that [ __ ] where i'm
kind of like
always feel like i have to be a people
pleaser all the time i always have to
like
make everybody happy and [ __ ] and now
i'm starting to be like nah [ __ ] that
like if i don't
think this is good or anything or
whatever the case i'm not gonna lie
about it
i'm not going to do this [ __ ] no more
i'm not going to do this guess who's not
a people pleaser
oh alex alex
and that's that's the other thing though
too is like i see how you react i'm like
and my buddy like like kenny candy's not
a people he's the opposite he's worse
than i am yeah he's a [ __ ]
he's a perpetual button pusher bro yeah
perpetual
and it's like low-key like i've never
even seen it i just always hear stories
yeah and i'm like oh i kind of need some
of that in my life
you know what i mean because i'm always
so not like i try to be really nice and
i try to be really helpful and [ __ ] but
sometimes you just can't be helpful
sometimes you just gotta tell
[ __ ] like no bro leave me alone
like i don't want to talk to you it's
hard right people can
not feel bad about it either people
pleasing is hard is because
your your end goal is in your mind
you're thinking that if i say this i'm
going to hurt somebody's feeling and
it's going to make them feel bad then
i'm going to feel bad
yeah but what happens is you just get
exhausted yeah you they they're taking
from you
oh [ __ ] much it's exhausting and then
you get wrapped up in situations that
you
don't want to be in and then you end up
thinking how the [ __ ] did i end up here
yeah like why do i say yes to this i
don't want to do this with anybody
yeah i'm kind of like that too though
yeah sometimes like
i do like i agree to [ __ ] or like i'm
just always trying to make sure
everything regrettable
yeah and then like i'm going like it's
coming up i'm like
[ __ ] i don't want to do this [ __ ] bro
and then i'm still just doing it and
it's just like
i have to find the balance between me
not wanting to do something and me being
me something beneficial for me because a
lot of times i'm not just i just don't
want to do [ __ ]
right so like if like for example i'll
be asked to do a podcast and i don't
[ __ ] know these people how do i do
this but i'm like you know this could be
a fun time you're talking about our
podcast
oh you mean [ __ ] gilbert he was like
hey you down to the podcast
oh yeah i'm down in 15 minutes go yeah
and then the day of a we're going to hop
on in 15 minutes you didn't give me a
date or a time jackass
we got excited about the fights that's
why i know whatever that's the same [ __ ]
remember
with bobby it's like bro you're
literally like
with bobby like you do this [ __ ] but i
have to text him
and ask him i'm like bruh just [ __ ]
ask him bro
he wanted you to do he's like no just
send a text and then just send a text
and send them a link
gilbert's ass dude yeah dude that's
what's going on what are you gonna have
gilbert in here
i do i gotta have him become shirtless
only though
he's like yeah i got that areola as big
as the lens bruh
yeah we just be [ __ ] on gilbert all
the time on this podcast he's not here
to defend himself yeah i love gilbert
though he's the best dude yeah he's fun
too would be a decent fighter if he
wasn't so spazzy low-key he's
he's he's picking it up though pretty
quickly great kick because he only
trained seven times out of the year
so when he does trade those seven times
it is very
beneficial bruh since i've known gilbert
right we have the the mma show and [ __ ]
i think i've only trained with him four
times this is the most we've ever
trained with him in a row yeah
ever and it's because of the weight loss
challenges that we're not always like he
goes oh i hate sparring with dave
because his arms are so much longer than
mine
we literally went arm length for arm
length same arm length we have the same
arm length
yeah talking about hey also oh i forgot
you weren't there last night
they told me that you guys were getting
downs hey these [ __ ] were going
10 second bodies but to the face instead
what are you talking about oh he wore it
always over exaggerated these things
yeah but you don't know [ __ ] you can't
even commit to a statement what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
childhood trauma your mom said you're
stupid and i agree
yeah you know what don't tell me
something you're right you're right
you're right yeah you weren't going 10
seconds
you said like brenda's shot now god damn
it
nah bro but um yeah david was [ __ ] up
not [ __ ] him up gilbert
cause gilbert was actually swi he was
chunking them things bro like
he was he was hanging in there with him
but i was like hey
chill out i was like stop throwing so
hard david i was i had to yell at that
david why did you say
he was throwing hard at hey let me tell
you something i pulled 90
of my shots except for when he cracked
me hard once i just gave him one hard
one back and
it slowed him down a bit well but yeah
you know i always put the blame on david
because he's more experienced and he's
the veteran but we're not we've all
trained the same amount of years
shut the [ __ ] up first of all i know
isn't he like a black belt in taekwondo
or something
yeah he does the ha ha ha ha the the
[ __ ] nunchuck [ __ ]
he's a black guy he has better kicks
than me
hey his kicks low key that day we were
kicking off the [ __ ] heart dude
he knows how to whip on bro i was like
okay like that's true because my homie
thick boy
so my homie kenji that i used to work
with at super air he used they used to
come to mission and train with me we
were starting to hold mitts
and he was like hey i'm going to bring
my friend i forget the kid's name i
think it's like michael or some [ __ ]
he's like i'm going to bring his wife
yeah i know i was like he's like
he's like he's also did karate with
kenji uh he i think you and kenji did
the same type of karate shuttle con
yeah or something like that um he's like
i want you to fill his kicks hardest
kicks you'll ever feel in your whole
entire life
all right cool and i've seen the guy
before like i met him before and he
comes
and he's training his his hands weren't
that good or anything but when he kicked
i was like
hard i was genuinely scared to hold
mitch for him
that's all i was like yeah it was
literally just the hardest kick i've
ever felt before how big was he
uh he's maybe maybe six foot
may i'm guessing maybe he's six foot
though 190 200 pounds maybe
damn that's like a big boy but bro like
but they were like i was like oh my god
imagine getting hit with this [ __ ]
like i feel like it would break people's
arms especially if this fool's saying
that
yeah he's one he's probably the most
dense person we know yep
i was genuinely surprised i was like oh
my god and kenji's like right
hardest kicks you'll ever feel that's
[ __ ] it was crazy but it is like even
javier mendez the guy that runs aka
said that that he they have that one
fighter um
but it's a hispanic guy on this team
he's like hardest kicker in the gym
and then one of the interviewers like
well he's like but you have like luke
rockhold and all that stuff for the
campy he's like
telling you right now hardest kicker in
the gym and he's a 145
wow yeah luke rocco kicks hard too big
boy
[ __ ] dude yeah gilbert though he he
could give to somebody he wasn't so
scared
if he wasn't so goofy and [ __ ] yeah and
his head's so big too like it's like he
could take a
shot boy yeah but it's an easy target
though kind of huh you could punch over
here
he's like he's like oh my head
oh my head
he just does a lot of stuff that uh it's
like when you first start you're very
spazzy
and you're just trying to flick out the
jab as hard as possible
so he's so tense he gets tired hella
fast yeah and literally i'm not doing
anything i'm just crowding him
i'm crowding crowding crowding crowding
and i'm like punching him in the face
hey
i'm just crowding crowding crowding
crowding crowding over the back of his
head
he's like i'm not doing anything over
i'm crowding you come on
hey literally i was doing this i was
doing this volume volume volume
yeah sometimes no ninety percent and
then other times he was [ __ ] blasting
this full
and i wanted the overall pace to be a
little lower right hey gilbert versus
dylan who wins
i think gilbert wins yeah gilbert wins
100
i i think gilbert just needs more time
bro yeah yeah i mean he hardly ever
trains
he has a phone call every three minutes
and he's not going to always have a
meeting i got a meeting
i got to be an artist distracted i got a
meeting this is gilbert oh yeah got some
kicks dude that's what hit me
really hard that's why i suck him in the
gut back really hard
i was throwing [ __ ] body hooks
david hit me
they showed us his pubes again for the
[ __ ] 30th time bro you got to get
gilbert on here to defend himself yeah i
love this guy he's like
gilbert he's so funny yeah text back you
know maybe every once in a while
but bruh the worst texture dog he really
does do that though like when you hit
him he goes
i'm like bro we're sparring and he looks
to like make a joke yeah
he's like such an entertainer oh bro he
hit me so hard
it was like we're literally sparring
right now
what are you doing dude but for as
little as he trains he did pick up a lot
of things very quickly
like pretty well like he gets it he he's
one of those guys and i'm just like gil
i just wish i had more time with you you
piece of [ __ ] she had long legs long
arms
very tiny torso the smallest torso i've
ever seen in mine he looks like a
pac-man actually
it'd be cool to see him like imagine him
in a street fight he'll probably beat
the
[ __ ] out of somebody very theatrical
yeah
[Laughter]
i don't sound like that yeah
gilbert's is i'm just going to call this
episode the roast of gilbert
was gilbert's last name again galon
that's hello
gallon i just remember too the first
time i ever hung out with him is when we
went fishing
and he just threw up half the time and
then this pool caught
the [ __ ] loch ness monster in the
[ __ ]
biggest fish i've ever seen in my life
this fool threw up so much
dude he was talking to me and he was
like yeah dude i just don't really
i just don't really feel that good right
now
my boy my boy a good actor though
because he played that [ __ ] off every
time i go talk to him he's like what's
up
what's up yeah i'm good mm-hmm then he
would sit there in a row like
do his [ __ ] rod and like i was born
in the ocean i do an invitation of him
getting his uh his hook caught
he's like oh [ __ ] hey alex alex my
shit's caught i think it's
constantly i'm like no dude i think you
got a fish nah nah nah it's not it's
caught
it's caught it's caught go check go
check it's caught i'm like
i go look i come over i'm like it's not
no definitely oh [ __ ]
oh it's caught it's caught it's not and
he goes he keeps going
bro this fool when he pulled it out the
fish head was literally like this
i [ __ ] you [ __ ] not the fish was
bigger than this
probably it was bigger than this [ __ ]
pillow bro it was ridiculous hey loki
because his rod was like this
yeah and i was like wait he actually
might be caught and he was like he's in
there struggling like struggling because
you know some
they set up two hooks on that
[ __ ] so sometimes you catch two
fish
and sometimes i'm like i thought i
worked out in this [ __ ]
that's just hard and yeah he pulled up a
fish that [ __ ] maybe like
[ __ ] what twelve thirteen thousand huge
it was a big [ __ ] fish
yeah and he had the biggest catch of the
day the biggest catch of the day but he
didn't put his money in for the drawing
dumbass what a [ __ ] one dude yeah you
wanna take your girl fishing and stuff
yeah she likes all this
so my girl used to work at yosemite so
she used to work on the trails like it's
pretty dope so she used to go and like
for a month
have to stay out there with like no
phone and [ __ ] like that she lives in
tents
holy [ __ ] she's bare girls bro basically
yeah for real
yeah so she on yosemite i think it's
only one month because she works over
the summers
and then the other two months she's like
at a campground and she works on the
crank round but she like
actually goes out to these like trails
and she
say there's like a rock protruding into
a trail like her job is to like put
these like metal things in and break up
that rock to open up the trail
so basically she like creates trails
throughout yosemite and [ __ ] like that
oh yeah so that last year was a
trailblazer yeah
there it is that's why her favorite
fighter is kevin holland
um no but she uh i think yeah last
summer was her last time doing it
but that's pretty cool because she's
into all that [ __ ] which i like to do i
like to fish
this [ __ ] mad cute dude this was like in
the explore my baby's hella dope bro
it's just funny look at this dude this
was the flute madden up i just can't
wait for you guys to fight man
i just love it the fighting parts are
the best part to me after we fight and
we make up i'm gonna facetime you we're
just gonna be laying
david we just had our first fight
just like this too so what'd you all
fight about the sky crew tattoo
she was talking some lightweight [ __ ]
about it she said the sky vodka line
actually
she listened to the podcast she said
arizona's hot trash
now she lived in arizona she loves
arizona so that one way we're hot
dad dude hello my brain
farts this podcast is brought to you by
skillshare listen let me cut to the
chase
you're like me you have hobbies you have
goals and a bunch of things you want to
learn and try but you don't know where
to get the right information and yeah
you can search online for hours for the
right class but i'm telling you you
don't have to deal
with that [ __ ] please just get
skillshare
no more snooping around online for
stupid stuff that you know can't teach
you anything skillshare
is an online learning community that
offers membership with meaning with so
much to explore real projects to create
and the support of fellow creatives
because skillshare is about
real growth listen the course i'm
checking out right now is youtube
success script and shoot
by marcus brownlee one of my favorite
online creators of all time and i've
been doing this a long time people but
doesn't mean i can't learn a little more
from people and all i
say is the greats all i say is the grace
what the hell am i saying
but yes marcus brownlee is is a top
creator online and i can learn something
from him
so remember explore your creativity at
skillshare.com
brain and get a free trial of premium
membership that's skillshare.com
brain yeah she cool bro that's weird
because obviously my last relationship
was
so [ __ ] like we had nothing in common
but working out
why did you [ __ ] bro i don't know
it's crazy to think that that [ __ ] was
like four almost four years ago now and
when you get wrapped up in though like
bro that [ __ ] went so it went by like so
fast but
it was just nothing was good about that
relationship so like low-key like when
we started talking it was like a little
weird
yeah you know i'm just like damn this is
like what a normal relationship but i
think you need a relationship like that
kind of not
not all the time but like it is a good
contrast to understand or appreciate the
next person that you yeah you've never
been dumped before huh i've been done
bro
there was a bro there was there was a
girl i was like
i was really liked before too also
hispanic
she was like she was like persian and uh
salvadorian or some [ __ ]
very quartered mix after he had to go
full salvador but like
but like i i was like i really liked her
only because she liked me that was
literally the only reason and we had
nothing in common we didn't really talk
but like
in my head i was like oh this is what i
had no
idea of what being in a relationship
means i was like a junior a bro i had no
[ __ ] idea what the [ __ ] i was doing
and i was like in love with this chick
for no real reason just
for the fact that i was like oh i have a
girlfriend now yeah kinda but we weren't
even really dating like that
but she was like yeah we should stop
talking because i was being like a
little i was being a little too much bro
i was being a little too clingy and [ __ ]
what do you mean clean what did you do
oh bro i just i was doing everything
anything you could imagine that's
cringey as a [ __ ]
like you would cause like i was hiding
under her bed at home yeah i was like
looking out of her window and i was like
hey what's up you know you're just all
that kind of
watcher i would be in here why are you
so obsessive i don't know
because i thought that's what you were
supposed to do and i learned real quick
that was like oh
i'm the crazy person like i'm i'm being
super like
like super lovey-dovey with her and she
was like okay like it's kind of weird
but whatever you know
like just being real over the top with
it that was pretty much like you got to
like
cards you got to like [ __ ] like yeah
we i didn't do
that bro i didn't do it but i would just
i would express like oh i really like
you and she was like all right bro like
chill like that's like she told me that
[ __ ] three like all right like
what's answer number six it's b but you
know i just [ __ ] feel so much for you
guys yeah
yeah yeah yeah like cringy [ __ ] like
that bro i think it's like it's be like
be my love you know hey low-key though
kind of how did you creep out a girl
that went after you
that's a skill life is crazy that's a
skill
dude how the [ __ ] did you do that that's
amazing i just got it like that bro
i got like that's actually really good
i've never heard of a story like that
you [ __ ] loser
oh my god i'm just telling you like
because my this is kind of [ __ ] sad
to say but
in my head at that time everything i
thought about relationships i learned
from like movies
i literally you're one of those i
literally thought like that's how you're
supposed to be you know what i mean
but i realized very quickly as soon as
she was like
nah i'm good bro like and she she was
yeah she
she did the right thing she [ __ ]
kicked my ass to the curb and i was like
oh [ __ ]
how long did that last i actually have
no idea
um i wish it was like three hours
and it was like hey let's hang out we
were actually never in a relationship
yeah we weren't like that's a thing like
we were like talking but that's when
it was crazy like i didn't oh you didn't
play it cool at all i didn't play cool i
was too excited i was too happy to be
there
i would people pleaser [ __ ] yeah funny
people please yeah no
just i would say things that i thought
like you know you're supposed to
yeah um but and then but i did really
like her though for
kind of but i when thinking back on it i
was like we didn't really talk much
it was just like some high school [ __ ]
you know what i mean and then
um what was the question again
my boy said but i 30 times and then
can't forget what he was saying let me
tell you something bro
this guy is never allowed to defend us
in court
[ __ ] ever he starts talking you just
see it if you start if nick's talking
his eyes start to go
and he closes his eyes and he goes you
just
go into jail hey you going to jail you
back that is the second time on this
podcast
this fool told a story that went [ __ ]
nowhere yeah that's my thing though
that's my thing
i [ __ ] hate you dude yeah you know
what it is though sometimes i like i
just kind of
i get bored when i start talking no but
i do that sometimes
because like i start when i'm talking
then i start remembering other stories
yeah yeah and i remember another story
yeah that's what it is that's what it is
and then i come back to be like
i said you have never had your heart
broken before oh yeah so yeah so yeah
she
she was like yeah we gotta stop talking
and i was like crushed bro i never felt
that ever but
it didn't even last that long how could
you be crushed i'm a [ __ ] bro like what
do you want from me that's all i wanted
to say
i was just waiting that's all i wanted
to say two question questions until you
said i'm gonna push
i give him i was waiting for that [ __ ]
thank god no but yeah no
just my yeah the last one i was in was
just so bad i didn't really want to be
in it like it wasn't like the goal from
like us
starting to talk because we were all
just like kind of homies and i remember
i was just talking about homie aaron
about this like
we had talked about it once because she
was an attractive girl
but like we had talked about it a long
time ago like he asked me he's like do
you think you could ever date her
and i was like i don't know ah like it's
just the way she is i was like ah no i
couldn't
like i just i couldn't see myself ever
doing it and of course that's the
[ __ ] girl i ended up with right
hey but she kind of gaslets you though
bro like she kind of she was playing
games she did everything
she started the the relationship but it
was just so bad she showed me what she
was doing but
so it's nice being in one now where it's
like it's neutral
like not everything doesn't have to be
hidden like i don't only have to talk to
her through instagram and
like we can go out in public and we do
[ __ ] in public
together who are the most abusive
relations that's what i mean
i'm sorry i shouldn't be laughing but
this was
bro she was she was super abused of this
fool and alex is such a good nice guy
and she knew he was innocent so she
could she could bro she
had him in the palm of your hand i could
text my girl now from
at least after 6 p.m from about 8 p.m
now
yo what kind of life are you [ __ ]
living she was crazy though
i could hold her head now in public
without her going uh yeah but it was
good
but that that's why i waited like
obviously hey bro that never happened
she never held my understanding now i
can hug her longer than three seconds
without her getting angry
oh man what a real relationship okay
stop [ __ ] stop hugging me yeah we're
good we're not
but no it's cool like i was single for
over three and a half years
so it's kind of just like this one kind
of just happened isn't that crazy too
and now you're like oh this is what a
nice person is like
exactly i'm like oh this is what it
feels like to be in a normal
relationship
like it's like relaxing we like doing
[ __ ] together we actually like to see
each other
y'all have your first [ __ ] bed source
yet little kiss yeah of course bro
this was mad cute that's my baby baby
here's
if you listen to this
my baby hella cool and you guys are
going to meet us who kissed you first
though
uh i made the first move on the kids hey
let's go guys
hey tell me what you felt like i felt
good bro you want to hear the whole
story
i want to hear the whole story the first
kiss story dude
stories told bro so we was at the
beginning
we was watching tv and [ __ ] right and so
it was like this thing that
i i think i picked it up from seeing my
mom's boyfriends
do this to her so let me because it
sounds weird but let me
there's this one guys used to date that
always played with her hair
and like i was a little kid right and i
see it but he always like put his
fingers through his hair
so as i got older like i kind of just
like doing it too because i used to see
oh my mom likes it you know i kind of
just grew up like
thinking like oh that's cool but so
we're at the house
and i was sitting and i put my arm
around her and then like
she was cool with it i was all right
cool so that we were there for a little
bit but then she moved a little bit so i
took my arm off and was like that
but then i did it again later on and
then like her hair kept going on my hand
right so i'm like alright this is my
opportunity right here bruh
so i i started like playing with her
hair a little bit you put her on the
steps you start cornrowing that [ __ ]
you want to sit outside all right let me
catch you ready for you
i was like i gave her a 40 ounce of old
english i lit up the blunt
and then i started braiding that you
know i'm saying what you finna get into
later
i messed up on my off [ __ ] my fault my
fault let me finish the [ __ ] rat tail
coat just lighting this [ __ ] up
hey what's up hey so what'd you for the
candy later today she's like nah and i'm
gonna go down to the stove
uh i might give me some hot cheetos and
i might come back and watch for some
power
opportunity right i was like all right
cool so i started like i was like oh can
i play with your hair
like you mind she's like nah so i was
playing with them we started talking you
know we was just
vibing now like staring at each other
and i just kissed her damn
let's go hey let me tell you got a
similar story right so i will marry all
right
and start playing with the hair that she
looked at me she goes don't [ __ ]
touch my hair
tickles i hate it when people touch my
hair and i haven't done it since
and we've been together for six years
that's a true story when i first started
dating tiff if i held
if i hugged her too much she's like can
you not hug me so much i'd be like damn
bro
you know what she seems so nice to tiff
so when i hear this [ __ ] i'm like
i'm like that's why she was trying to
fight me and [ __ ] bro she'd be mean as
[ __ ] to me sometimes i'm like
yeah you better relax dude you know what
the [ __ ] weirdest thing is
is like girls typically i'm pretty sure
any woman that's listening to this
usually like it
when their man plays with their hair
they like it's actually very relaxing
you like scratch their scalp or whatever
it feels super good
marielle is the only girl i know that
[ __ ] hates it
it actually pitches her off it puts her
in a rage she
hates it and so it's weird because i
actually
like it i just like doing it in general
yeah i joke around about the braiding
hair
like doing this i used to do that [ __ ]
to this girl named leslie cruz in high
school
i used to just braid her hair in math
class because i'd be bored as [ __ ]
just like this hey dave you just have a
lime bruh
yeah who else gonna sit on the stream
and watch the power line with me he
wants to watch some power
just be brightening that [ __ ] up and so
i like playing with girls hairs
like it's nice you're so stupid bro yeah
he had the like the the cream and rub it
on his fingers put it in there
yeah i got the rat dope i'm telling you
man i got
that purple that purple uh [ __ ] comb
with the like twist at the end so you
can go
hey man i'm telling you bro rat tail i
got the rat tail combs i got the grease
i got everything i'm
but i'd be like [ __ ] messing with
girl's hairs because they used to love
that [ __ ] and i just enjoyed it in
general like it used to be very
cathartic for me
yeah but marielle hates it and i've
never been with a woman
who didn't like it when i would play
with their hair and now it's weird
because sometimes i just do it out of
habit and she goes what the hell did i
just tell you don't
[ __ ] touch she talks to her teeth at
you yeah she goes oh [ __ ] you're gonna
knock you out
[ __ ] rip your pubes out and feed it
to you at night you're like
don't [ __ ] threaten me with a good
time it's been good though bro
it's been a good relationship damn was
that your first [ __ ]
besitos in like how many years yeah like
three years damn dude was that weird hey
tell me that was a little weird that was
like damn i haven't had this in a minute
yeah but it felt good because
you didn't have to hide it honestly
honestly there's probably some girls and
[ __ ] that i could have gotten with and
stuff like that throughout these three
years
but uh i didn't want to you know i was
just i want to make sure like i'm cool
with it and
during this time like nowadays i'm like
yeah it'd be cool to have a girl were
you kind of nervous like damn i don't i
don't even remember how to kiss anymore
nah hey that's what that ph for let's go
baby
oh okay let's go i wasn't nervous
honestly this whole time it's been real
cool like everything's just like
it's just been panning out and working
we didn't rush anything
like we didn't rush to immediately say
like we're boyfriend and girlfriend
we kind of just want to chill like
become friends and kind of see how each
other were and [ __ ] like that and
everything kind of fell in place but
it's
that's when it's good man that's when it
feels nice wait until you get to his
part man
[ __ ] 11 years in yeah he's over here
pissing her off every day dude
yeah i mean yeah she'll be here recently
bro
cool she wants to meet everybody too she
likes all you guys from like the
instagrams and [ __ ] that's
i like that's what that's the type of
[ __ ] i like that she wants to like get
involved with like what i do
i want to or like i'm trying to already
be friends and she's trying to get a box
with her bro
hey bro me too bruh she's probably beat
us
so yesterday we were like at the gym
messing around right and like i was just
she
said something and i was like pretending
to mess with her i'm like oh and then
you like sock me in my face and start
laughing she's like yeah just do that
but she like threw like a shadow box
punch in my head i'm like damn my baby
low-key can throw a punch she's got some
hair
colored glasses right now yeah watch
that [ __ ] wasn't even nice
it was like bro she's like exactly
israel on a sonia
she better than rose number eunice baby
hey that's some bold statements dude the
way she knocked out our [ __ ]
champions
hey when's david finna fighting hey who
would david's uh best matchup be
hey i'm dropping down to 115 who's
trying to [ __ ] with me
yeah who tried to [ __ ] with me only on
loki i think david could probably get a
fight with one of these big youtubers
like who
let's see a fun bro
bro i eat those boys up boy that's not
even that's not even [ __ ]
i saw you had the one guy on here that
fought at pat's thing right
did you oh jason yeah jason jason cheney
yeah yeah
you know why he lost though he doesn't
like fighting he was like i didn't want
to hurt the guy even though he
why'd you box that even though he hates
me and he was talking all the [ __ ]
i didn't want to hurt the girl remember
how mad we were especially like when
they were like
oh my girlfriend and like the other
people were talking talking [ __ ]
oh we were like waiting for him to come
in the back and they of course they ran
out the front i was like
[ __ ] bro everybody wanted to beat his
ass and jason cheney still had a great
attitude bro yeah what a [ __ ] gem
this we're like why don't you come train
with us oh i'm not that good it's like
[ __ ] we're at we're telling you come
train
and then run that fight back dude yeah
yeah let's see who would david fight
if i do i i would think it's surging on
this knee first though like this is not
about boxing
boxing dude i gotta get surgery on this
knee see that's how david he takes the
[ __ ] serious bro
yeah good hey good get surgery on that
knee and we finna set this [ __ ] up
i'll get surgery on this knee and i will
train every [ __ ] day until i bleed
dude
i'm not losing i refuse to lose if i
lose to somebody then i let's say like
it's like some youtuber that never box
i'll kill i'll kill myself and he gets
beat by auntie
but it's not backwards i'll kill myself
i'll sign up for to a real [ __ ]
boxing gym i'll get rounds and
i'll drop everything yeah i'm not losing
to a guy that doesn't box you see the
fire in his eyes bro
i refuse i'm telling you bro he got it
he got the hate in his heart would you
prefer to do boxing or kickboxing if his
kickball i would prefer kickboxing i
would
love to [ __ ] rip somebody's legs in
half oh my god bro see hey you're
getting his his dick is hard right now
you know let's tell you guys listening
at home and watching this
hey that [ __ ] levitating what's going on
is this guy him thinking about breaking
someone's leg off
he's literally dick oswalt yeah
it'd be fun i i don't think like i got
one i fought that guy i got to hit him
hard but we had like pads on you know
yeah like i hit him once really hard
with like the low kick
that kind of like hurt his leg and then
like i threw a really hard overhand
and it hit his like i just know that if
i get into a
a fight i got my conditioning has to be
like a thousand times better
aerodyne sprints all day yeah i don't
know it's just gonna have to be road
work
it's road work all the time i have to do
it because i just now that i've did that
one little session with savann
i got a taste of how hard it is to fight
for you know three minute rounds at a
time
it's damn hard dude yeah because all the
movement you're constantly on your bike
all the time and i'm not even throwing
punches you just like throw faints and
then move your feet
about to throw up after three uh one
round that's me right now but that's
also you coming off of you not doing any
training
bro so still dude i'm just saying
respect to fighters dude it's it's hard
and i think a lot of these young
youtubers they don't understand what
it's like
and then when they go in they gas out in
the first round and they're tired it's
like that's what's cool bro like
that's the whole thing bro you go fight
one of these youtubes that are all just
doing it for fun go make a [ __ ] bag
bro you know what i'm saying
i mean if i if do a youtube fight it
would have to be for a lot of money
what's your number what's the minimum
500 000.
hey you could probably sell 500 000
people i would have to do 500
for me to almost get concussed like you
have to yeah
that'd be great yeah if you give me a
half a mil let's go
let's do it right now i'll [ __ ] i'll
do the fight tomorrow and then i'll get
knocked out and like
david how'd it feel hey your boy hawaii
right now chilling hey [ __ ] seat
is there any youtubers that hate david
everybody hates me bro
name them i'm trying
at least for eight months hey we should
just do like a a makeshift fight camp
for all of us bro you know we ain't
going to do that [ __ ] man
we did we did the weight loss challenge
we didn't do that [ __ ]
no one bro no one actively started
dieting
yeah man i know but like okay but like
well let's let's try you know
hey bro we've had this conversation
we've been friends for three years now
it ain't happening bro come on now
i'm like saying let let's change it
let's get together and try
i think you wanna train anymore yeah i
wanna start training but i wanna like it
would be cool like imagine all of us
went through like a mini like fight camp
style thing
and like did like the ropes do that with
pat bruh we did that with that was
exhausting that's true but it was fun
yeah that [ __ ] was fun bro but we didn't
do nothing else
yeah yeah everything else suffered a
relationship
we're 100 our relationship suffered our
businesses suffering
we only did boxing and [ __ ] too and then
the first time i kicked i could kick
like
three feet off the floor she hurt my
hips yeah but
that's why because i think we had fun
like when powell was getting ready for
that boxing fight like we always had
we had like a mission every time we were
training all right we know pat's getting
ready for this fight
so it is it is different like when you
guys have
a whole team of guys that are getting
ready for fights like the atmosphere
energy's up and then when you have the
whole gym kind of like rallying behind
you and [ __ ] like that's a real cool
feeling
but that's just for the birds bro yeah
i'm okay getting punched in the face it
would have to be for a sizeable amount
of money
where i'm okay getting knocked out
there's still a chance i can get knocked
out i don't know who it would be
yeah but it's like i don't know for uh
asian american pacific islander month
set me up with a [ __ ] fight let's go
dumbfounded i'm hitting you up let's go
bro
oh [ __ ] how big is he though oh he's
kind of getting yolked he's yolked right
now is he he's buff as [ __ ] about like
like
height like height wise is he oh he's
tall he's almost my height
is he really he's like 5 11. i've always
thought he was like
five eight five i thought he was like
average height guy no that was because
he
he was built like a [ __ ] gamer at
first but now but he's lifting huh bro
he's yolk now
really yeah that looks good he's
dumbfounded he's a rapper he's a friend
of mine
i'm [ __ ] around like me and double
friends i'm saying like if
dumb is like close to my heart he's like
five eleven maybe i had no idea he was
that tall he's tall as [ __ ] and he's
joke now he's buff
oh [ __ ] yeah do i [ __ ] him right now you
intend
to fight him oh he's tied dude he has
something in him that i don't know about
he got empty
bro i think he could take some shots is
that how you send foods with yeah
i don't know i i i don't know i might do
it but it has to be for a good amount of
money i don't think people understand it
hurts to get punched
it hurts it's not fun yeah you guys are
crazy
they don't hurt like it's a weird
feeling and bro you [ __ ] weird man
bro but look at your head though yeah i
there's literally a clip of me
connecting to this fool's dome
and then i asked him are you okay he
goes you hit my shoulder i was like
maybe i look at the clip i hit him
directly on the dome
and then my hand hurt i was like he ate
that his neck didn't even move bro it
didn't
have to even move and this was like nah
it was my shoulder i was like
really looking for me like dome and then
my hand is pulsing
like say like when i spar with nick
right and he like picks it up and like
throws more volume
it's not that it hurts it like makes me
tired it's just annoying yeah it's just
like tiring because like you're just
getting hit constantly you're just like
okay i can't breathe because like i
can't like you know it's just always but
like it never really nothing really ever
hurts
i don't think i've ever really been hurt
well i think that one time i was holding
mitts
for like i remember like when it was
like ricky and mark
when we were training for pat's fight
and i was holding mitts for everybody um
and i didn't have a body patch i was
letting everybody like hit me in the
body
it was like towards the end my body
started hurting because
you guys were all hitting me in my body
without a body pad and i was like okay
it's starting to get a little that hurt
me
pat hit me with the guts a lot dude
that's when i was like oh body shots
work he kind of he kind of hit hard
though like out of nowhere and [ __ ] his
body shots were hard dude they [ __ ]
hurt i've been hit with a hard body shot
at 10th planet when i used to train
there
um we were training and like the old
coach there he actually just moved back
to louisiana alan choban right we were
going over this drill
and i think it was like a one two and
then a slip to the outside and like body
hook
like right here like the liver punch or
the [ __ ] yeah and he was like
he's like all right he's like i want you
guys to throw to the body
he's like we're not gonna like block it
but just like eat it he's like but
whoever's throwing it
throw it light like just kind of like
you know hit him yeah
i'm going with this kid and he's a
bigger kid so they we always partnered
up together
and literally his first two punches were
like this
and then he goes and hits me right like
hard as [ __ ]
and i stood there he's like oh [ __ ] my
bad that was hard but you mean my bad
bro
it's so [ __ ] annoying that's what he
said he's like oh [ __ ] my bad
that was hard and like for real i just
played it off you know i got a good
race on my oh no it's cool but like
literally it sent a shooting pain from
like my trap
all the way down to my face especially
when you're not braced for it yeah and i
was just like
that's that's the saying right when they
say the shot that you don't see coming
hurts the most
yeah is that type of [ __ ] that's like
the hardest one i was hit with that
actually like sent
it was like a weird pain like from like
right here like down to my foot and i
was like
damn actually all right if you weren't
if you were like kind of chilling
yeah especially because his first two
punchers are bom ba
and then i'll say yeah there's a mutual
understanding
what the [ __ ] is wrong with this guy the
same kid yeah i think because i was new
right like i was just
[ __ ] and then like i remember
sparring we were sparring and i had just
did three rounds and
i mean y'all know me one brother get
tired i try to like rest a little bit
right
so like like i did like three rounds and
like for me it was like a good thing for
me because i was like i was just getting
back into it i was like [ __ ] i lasted
three rounds
and i go and sit down and the same kid
goes hey alex let's borrow let's do
around
i was like oh no like all right those
are always the worst literally
so i get up and i go because i know
[ __ ] right i'm like all right whatever
and then i go and then literally like we
touch glove the round starts he's like
all right but let's pick it up
and then he starts going at me bro and i
was already tired so i just sat there
and he just like
punched beat the [ __ ] out of me for a
whole round and it's just like all right
and then afterwards i was like cool he's
like he goes far right he's like so what
you got to do and then so oh and this is
all
so new right this is going to make you
guys laugh
and make you mad because especially now
i know where this is going
especially nowadays because of what i do
right with my job
so afterwards like we're in the locker
room and all that type of [ __ ]
and i have my uh i have so i bought some
pro boxing blues at the time
about 16 ounces right i'm like sitting
there and everybody's taking off their
gloves and i'm like looking at their
gloves at 12
10 12 from the kids that were i was
sparring with
and same with the kid that i was
sparring with 12 ounces
10 ounces so now i text my friend derek
federico flores he fights out of fight
ready right
he's a pro fighter at this time so i
messaged him like hey
should i get some uh some 10 ounces or
12 ounces for sparring
it's like why would you do that i was
like oh no because i was like i thought
always like 16 because that's what we
used to use back in the day
i was like but the guys that i'm
sparring with these bigger guys they're
all using 12 and 10 ounces god damn
that's crazy
and he's like he's like definitely not
that's kind of a [ __ ] dick [ __ ]
movie
that's just a straight knuckle yeah i
was like oh
all right so yeah they were using like
12 ounces and 10 ounces the whole time
and i had 16 ounces on and [ __ ]
i was like damn but [ __ ] that dude hey
look at that the the cyan boxing dudes
they're all like
16 18 ounce gloves those gloves are big
as [ __ ] they're huge they know they're
throwing
i love my 18 ounce gloves i have those
onyx gloves those are like 18 oz gloves
those guys are using big ass gloves yeah
they're protecting the 18 ounces on him
don't look like 18 ounces they're like
10s they look like [ __ ] they look
like mma gloves
i love them [ __ ] yeah nice i don't know
about those ones without velcro because
my man's over here [ __ ] almost took
my eye out with that velcro bro
hey i didn't know that happened that she
was crazy that [ __ ] was weird because it
was like
required because like we had like
clinched up and like when i when we
exited out
like it all i it just burned like it was
just really hot for a second
by the cheat code he couldn't throw body
shots because my budget was yeah
it was [ __ ] up which is good for me
though like i gotta do that more because
like
right when i didn't throw body shots
like it made it
night and day difference like i was like
i don't know what the [ __ ] to do
so i need to do this it was [ __ ] up
dude like breathing hurt at that time so
it was like
if you touched it it i would have
exploded oh i've had those two
bro like david gets the weirdest
injuries by the way yes
really weird very painful i've had this
one so this one time there's this
there's this bar called the safety squat
bar
right oh yeah yeah you know which one
it's like the pad you hold it right here
yeah
and so like one day i had this dumb idea
we were working out
and i was like uh i do body shots while
i do these squats
so i like talked to i used to work out
with chris and like all the guys that
own mission
and i was like hey let's do this thing
where like we tie this to our we tie
this to us
let's not pull weight on it but then we
dead lift
because like the weight is throwing you
forward so you really have to force
yourself to stay upright and
stay back and people do this now but i
swear on my life we was the first ones
to do this [ __ ] [ __ ] bro
this was literally like six and a half
years ago when we did this
so we tie it on us and we're doing the
deadlifts we can barely do a plate
because the bars it was just so awkward
i can't i like i literally like
contemplated going to the hospital
the next day i was so sore
like i could not even like lean down
like to sit down it was like
five seconds i was like why would you do
that your lower back
my low back was tore the [ __ ] up and i
was working merch at best buy
so we were having to move boxes and [ __ ]
bro that was the worst like four days of
my life because i could
barely [ __ ] move and your low back
gets [ __ ] up
my lower back already gets [ __ ] up so
man you just gotta drop some weight bro
i know bro i'm trying to i've been
eating healthier hey
again shout out my boo back to beginning
cause she be making me
clean and [ __ ] hey can i just say this
right now if we walked outside this room
my man came in this house with a bag of
funyuns and a dr pepper
i don't know bro hey dr pepper i need
you to shut the [ __ ] up
hey we was busy there i barely ate and i
was like [ __ ] i'm coming
light real quick i haven't been genius
brown i need to [ __ ] have some energy
to [ __ ] turn up i got some funyuns
hey let me tell you something man
there's a couple of hood snacks out
there in this world
funyuns is one of them bunions and then
[ __ ] the chili corn fritos you know
what another one is
bottles the chili cheese ones though
cheddar sour cream ruffles
there you go that's the third one okay
but that's like more that's not
ghetto that's kind of like that's a
little and then [ __ ] l.a
takis takis takis like i remember when
takis came out they weren't my [ __ ]
though
it tastes like battery acid it's like a
little i can eat them now
but it's weird like i feel like you have
to eat them like bear
it like you know you have to use your
fingernails to hold them you know that's
weird
hella acidic and it's super salty bro
that's just my tongue that's going to
burn a hole through you bro
100 easy yeah and you remember like
lucas and [ __ ] bro you if you lose
15 pounds 150 bucks i'll get to you
fitting pounds i don't play with you hey
bro i'll lose 15 pounds in three days
like [ __ ] you got to keep keep it off
for a month
oh [ __ ] no longer longer than that
i know i'm for real trying like i said
we've been eating healthier i've been
eating healthier being a lot more
fish now like fish and greens i've been
trying to make sure i'm eating greens
every day
uh chicken i haven't really been eating
red meat that much
i don't know why i mean all that stuff
is fine you just gotta make sure your
calorie is good
that's what i mean yeah we're just track
bruh i guarantee you track for a little
bit you'll be fine
and i've been weight training i've been
consistent with my weight training
so i feel like i'm losing weight i feel
lighter and [ __ ]
so we've been walking i've been walking
more i've been hiking again
bro this sounds like an aaa meeting for
a fat person right now
i only had three pieces of cake this
week i promise
is full right now yo i swear to [ __ ]
god bro
am i trying to convince you guys i
promise something i promise
yo i'm gonna get to know your girl real
close it's like yo what's he really
eating
this [ __ ] is sleep eating
you see a [ __ ] nest cam with a bag of
funnies being opened in the middle of
the night
um loki though i've been [ __ ] around
with these uh
there's like you know those like this
stomach just raw bro you heard that huh
i was right in front of this [ __ ] too
that [ __ ] picked that [ __ ] up bro
even your stomach knows you're lying
right now bro he's like oh shut the [ __ ]
up we had seven slices yesterday
oh bro what are you talking about bro
but i haven't had papoosa since we had
them
bruh this i've seen i've never seen
anyone put down oh yeah we were all
there
five papoosas in one sitting bro
and papoosas are like if you don't know
what they're very heavy
yes not bro i could eat cheese and i'm
good bro and i'm a pretty big eater see
the issue with me is i eat fast
it's like i eat that [ __ ] fast i don't
even give my body time to recognize that
i'm full yeah you ever see a duck eat
my man right here
it with his mouth and he [ __ ] his head
back and he goes down his gullet
yeah but no no so like these uh have you
had like the pretzel thins
the chips yes they're shaped as the
pretzels yeah they're everything bagel
ones
bomb bro we get those two doug i've been
there tonight bro
at night bro i almost go through i can
almost go through a whole bag of that
[ __ ]
they're so addicting those are so many
calories
what this will just say a few moments
ago can we rewind that back for a second
see hey
i've been eating healthy bro cut to here
hey you know those chips i go through a
bag easy
i'm talking about that no no no i said i
could
almost go through a whole bag no that
means you do i'm not saying i didn't
accidentally one night
but like i bought a new bag two days ago
and i literally i was like i only get
two little handfuls
and that's it at night because like
right when i'm in bed yeah cause harry
potter back on hbo i've been [ __ ]
binge watching that [ __ ]
so my two little handfuls um i did eat a
whole bag of shrimp chips though
hey cut to a clip of his instagram and
watch this full with a handful of food
means to this guy
this [ __ ] have you seen his
handful bro yeah this [ __ ] go to
town dude hey bro just track doug
i guarantee you you'll be down 15 real
quick
yeah i know i need to i want to
just just because bro it's like if this
is something you really want to do if
you just want to do that you'll be
got lower back problems and [ __ ] come on
man that's what i mean it wasn't that
bad last time
yeah last time we trained you got too
much muscles my whole thing is i gotta
stretch and i'm
so bad at stretching like i never
stretch and never
hardly ever like yeah we don't stretch
huh never like warm up that much because
you're a real power lifter that's what
yeah and so it's just like i think
that's my issue right now my issue is my
[ __ ]
knees bro like now that i'm not like
lifting lifting anymore like i used to
my knees are actually like tore up like
they always
feel like you know when like they're
really cold like if you get really
really cold on your knees
i'm sure you know because you have knee
issues just right knees like that all
the time yeah it always feels like it
like needs to pop or something like have
you been feeling that
more recently since you've been walking
a lot over quarantine yeah over
quarantine like
over those times i was just sitting a
lot and not doing [ __ ] yeah that's when
i started to feel like even right now
because we haven't moved in a while like
here this right yes this hurts right
here that's why i've switched
yeah that's why i've switched my legs
like six times yeah because like the
knee will start to hurt too much and
then i switched it but after you stretch
it
and then you strengthen this stuff it
feels good like yeah if i stretch this
it'll feel perfectly
once you get i think for you too like
you're probably so wound up if you just
do a little mobility
it'll probably save you a lot of trouble
some yoga my girl been trying to make me
do yoga
so your boy about to be on that yoga mat
like you're about to sit down with me
hey man yo this will traumatize me
you're training this [ __ ] it was
crazy
just hold real quick your boy got cake
hey we're making a dance yeah i was
making it
this [ __ ] threw his cakes back
so hard that [ __ ] traumatized me i've
never been so traumatized by ash cheeks
in my life dude
i threw up seven times and he threw up
by he threw up that
money baby he's like hey do that one
more game but don't
get rid of that dude again but don't hey
dave was biting his lip the whole time
too
don't don't say this bro and he was like
he was like bro i can kind of move them
hips bro
he was a worm dude so that's why i like
that moment yeah he can do the worm it's
crazy it's the most disturbing thing
i've ever seen in my life alex can do
so much weird [ __ ] that's what someone
his size wants to be able to
do his weird [ __ ] it's like it's like
you saw a [ __ ] whale in the ocean
just start walking
on land
it's like they bring out the singers are
smoking like i can do a mean cartwheel
remember when yoshi was teaching us that
[ __ ] yeah i was like getting that [ __ ]
down i felt kind of cool i was like oh
[ __ ] i can do this
like no no-hand cartwheel now like i was
able to like do no hands on a cartwheel
but this man won't stretch his lower
back at all like
you keep [ __ ] around doing those
cartwheels you're gonna hurt some [ __ ]
you're exactly you ain't trying to be
like me with this [ __ ] up knee
yeah i know wanna know what really did
it though and it's like
it's kind of sad so i bought some new
nike shorts right
and like they're flexible like walking
straight but it's like
opening up my legs like horizontally is
when they would get locked up on the
sides
and like i don't know how you get in
your car but like i'm more of like a
faller
you know what i'm saying like when you
get in like you fall into
what you mean like like show me a
demonstration
like you step in you just you just kind
of like plump down
it's not bro man you need an
intervention man bro you need to be more
mobile dog yeah you hear that [ __ ] hey
you know what that sounds like
that sounds like you need to lose some
weight bro bro you literally say
you fall into your car like a pin like a
pin from a bowling alley
what if he falls and he's like oh [ __ ] i
gotta get back up yeah bruh like i
pulled a step and it kind of just almost
like kind of i
kind of like throw myself in like it's
like a motion but it's kind of hard for
you to get in and out of the car
no no it's not hard for me to get out
yes because my legs are so big
and the steering wheel's right there i
don't like my steering wheel high i like
it like to the lowest setting
you know what i say so like i can't just
like pick my leg up i kind of hey i like
myself like this i've never said this to
anybody in my life
you lose some [ __ ] weight you fat
[ __ ] no
even when i was in shape bro my legs are
just from another fat man
you gotta get it together man this is
like another fat dude
you gotta lose some weight this man said
listen bro hey you know when you get in
the car there's a couple ways to do it
you just [ __ ] die yeah there's a you
passed out
there's a like i do what it was a trust
fall
this whole trust falls into his car
catches me every time it works every
time
what is it ninety percent of the time
um no no but like that's how it always
is my legs are so big and i put i'm
telling i put the steering wheel all the
way down
like it so it's really like
uncomfortably low alex drives like this
yeah so i like it low because i like to
like be able to chill and just
see everything so um but no so i wear
those shorts
and the whole thing with me it's my legs
are really big but my waist isn't big
like i i have only like a 34 inch waist
but like i need to wear 36 [ __ ] crazy
that's like a lot of uh uh power lifters
are like that yeah that's like my weight
jeans currently right now is still 34
but my legs are so big so i have to wear
36 and [ __ ]
but i always get large shorts because if
i get extra large like the [ __ ] waist
is just [ __ ] gigantic
but i got these new nike shorts so
they're not too stretchy
um but so when i was getting in my car
and i was stepping in and i did like my
hole when i stepped in i kind of just
like go there
like a low-key like i felt like a little
pinch in my knee
like in my left knee and i was like my
guy that wasn't right that ain't your
nike shorts bro
that's your lifestyle that's your bad
habits i
swear it like locked me in like i
couldn't like
reach anymore with my legs and it kind
of i felt my knee
you gotta throw those shorts away bro
bro i know like so when i do wear them
now like i'm really like it's like it's
like that stiff board short material
yeah exactly
[ __ ] but i have to worry because i spent
45 [ __ ] bucks almost bro imagine you
[ __ ]
you [ __ ] up your knee because you're
wearing some really tight-ass shorts
why'd you why'd you turn your back on
target oh no i just had discord good one
day dude hey
talk about target bro i'm sorry the best
salesman around for target
so let's motion you need to send him all
in motion bro whatever
they just released these new shorts
right so i went in uh
two days ago so they got these new
shorts they go by waist size
yeah but they're like really thin bro
they're the little like bumpy ones they
have braille bro i put those on
i got because my waist is 30. i put them
on and i was like i can't [ __ ] wear
these
i got 36. so i went up one are do they
feel good
they feel good yeah they feel like are
they smaller than normal yeah they were
they felt like bike shorts i felt like i
was wearing tights and i was like i
don't like
this right yeah they have like the navy
blue ones
i got the navy blue ones yeah that's the
ones i got and i got a 36
i got 36. are they comfy [ __ ] they're
actually really comfortable they're
stretchy too
and when you move your leg they ride up
so they don't get locked in like those
[ __ ] nike shorts right so get in my
car
perfect and so but they got these new
shorts
i don't know if you saw them they had
like all black ones they had like purple
ones
but they have pockets and then they have
the built-in underwear
they send me a link bro that come to
life it comes like right above the knee
right here so i've been watching this
show called my 600 pound life
bro you sound just like them right now
yeah like they have sweat
pants and that's it it's like so how do
you get how do you get into your car how
do you live your everyday life
well what happens is when i get into my
car i kind of straighten up my leg and i
just trust fall into my core
yeah bro if there's a procedure and a
science to get in your car and doing
like menial things
yeah well how do you get in your car i
just [ __ ] i just stay in my legs and
i sit
well it's different i know i'm gonna
defend myself mine's different because i
got a short car
loki when i had the miata obviously i
had to like it was maneuvering but that
car
is this big yeah but my car is low too
like this when i open the door if the
seat's not right here it's down here
and this year we're gonna we're gonna
have to jump that car and get a new car
man i want to bruh that's the goal i
only got like
i think a year and a half left on it
payment wise sell that [ __ ]
so i can i can even probably go trade it
in too but i didn't get a new car my
whole thing is i
could get a new car even now if i wanted
to but like the car
works and it's good on gas so i'm kind
of just like
do i really need one right now you know
especially right now when money is like
a little like different because of kovid
but i want to definitely get a new one i
want to get a bigger one i need a bigger
car i'm a bigger person and we're gonna
start a gofundme for this fool for some
new shorts in a car
hey no shorts i don't know hey target i
already went and got my new shorts hey
target's new [ __ ] you need to go i'm
telling you bro
they got purple they got black they got
navy then they got all these cool
designs
but the shorts are nice bro you're
getting to see alex in real action bro
like this is real
i don't know why you don't even work at
target bro because it there's
because you could be a rep for all the
moments at target you'd kill it
i probably would bro even best buy the
whole thing with those types of jobs i
can never go
back because of black friday i don't
know i think that's just hard
have you ever worked a black friday
anywhere have you guys ever watched oh
yeah
at a restaurant but that was it yeah so
they're like right in a restaurant
where'd you work out for black friday
uh men's warehouse whereas yeah so
retail it's just like no matter what so
nobody was lining up over there though
weren't they oh yes they were
they line up everywhere no matter what
the [ __ ] store it is bro people what
kind of people would line up at men's
warehouse
80 year old men yeah
i don't think i could ever go back to a
retail spot like that
is in 2011 i started at best buy
and then we opened at midnight on like
the day after thanksgiving
that was the last year at best buy they
did that after that starting 2012 they
started opening
on thanksgiving right but it was at five
and because i was a lead and i had to be
there
for the opening i had to get through at
three so i didn't have thanksgivings
for like five years right then i moved
out here i was still working there i
worked
my i worked thanksgiving at the pasadena
one
then i was able finally to quit and then
i had thanksgivings for like two years
and then i went back to best buy
and when i went back to best buy i
didn't need to but i did i didn't think
about that like i forgot about black
friday
so then i went back and i worked another
one but i just couldn't do that [ __ ]
it's just
rough i mean that's it it's a lot we
gotta do black friday here baby
yeah we just live our life well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brain
podcast we talked about alex's new love
life yeah yeah i'm talking about this
manchester [ __ ] trust falling into
his car i had no idea that's what
happened
i literally never seen you get into your
car ever and we're gonna watch it though
you can catch alex at lyft god that's
what three f's
two f's two d's baby all right two f's
and two d and we got nick at nick the
ear you could find him everywhere on the
instagrams
did you go find them at uh [ __ ]
what's what's your guys podcast we out
here mma baby yeah
i was about to call it fight club i
[ __ ] up we out here today
and we'll see you all next time peace